jk rowling slammed a new transgender
bill that would lower the age at which a
person can legally change their gender
to
from 18 to 16 a move that she said will
hurt the most vulnerable women in our
society the first minister of scotland
nicola sturgeon introduced a gender
recognition reform bill
that allows a trans person to legally
change their gender and receive a new
birth certificate with their gender on
it through easier means than before
the author said the law nicola
sturgeon's trying to pass in scotland
will harm the most vulnerable women in
society though seeking help after male
violence rape and incarcerated women
statistics show that imprisoned women
are already far more likely to have been
previously abused
rawling followed up her post
noting that multiple women's groups have
presented well-sourced evidence to
nicola sturgeon's government about the
likely negative consequences of this
legislation for women and girls
especially the most vulnerable and as we
know jk rowling has been on this sort of
crusade and i say that in the most
positive way possible
um
for a long time and as she was going
back and forth about this on twitter
so someone hit her with the thing that
i'm very familiar with which is uh the
old are you sure you want to die on this
hill
and a woman by the name of wanda said to
jk rowling you really want your legacy
to die on this hill jk rowling and
rowling responded yes sweetheart i'm
staying right here on this hill
defending the right of women and girls
to talk about themselves their bodies
and their lives in any way they damn
well please you worry about your legacy
i'll worry about mine
um
i mean this this is real courage from jk
rowling and i'll always give her credit
for it even though if she were ever made
aware of who i am she would probably
hate my guts and disagree with
everything that i say except on the
topic of gender and even on the topic of
gender she'd probably disagree with most
of what i say because she's not even
taking the position that transgenderism
itself is uh is sort of like incoherent
at least she's not openly taking that
position she's taking a much more
minimalist approach to this
and really focusing on the ways that you
know women the
children are indoctrinated into it uh
you know the way women's sports teams
are being invaded locker rooms and
prisons and that sort of thing
but even that minimalist
approach to this issue will still put
you in line for an unimaginable
avalanche of hatred and outrage
especially if you're someone like jk
rowling as famous as she is and famous
not um in you know
conservative media but famous
mainstream
having cultivated this fan base
um many of whom you know are leftists
and she has chosen just because she
believes in this issue she has chosen to
yeah she's got a billion dollars but
she's chosen to do something that's
going to alienate many of her fans it's
going to hurt her career prospects going
forward and it's going to detract from
her bottom line and i guarantee it
already has
um and even if you have a billion
dollars i mean even if you have money in
power we've seen that it takes courage
to do that and that is courage that
almost no one in our culture has
to do something
because it's the right thing
knowing that you will not benefit from
it in any way
you're not going to benefit financially
you're not going to benefit with more
fame i mean jk rowling can't get more
famous than she already was
you're not going to benefit by all the
applause and adulation you receive
because instead you're going to be
mocked and jeered
almost no one has the courage for that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content